we as humans ourselves are highly social
and so much of our lives revolves around
communication and then you see these
tiny critters on the floor and you see
that they also communicate right they
they follow each other and they seem to
coordinate their actions and immediately
you start to feel some kind of
connection to these guys
[Music]
so what I find most fascinating about
answers how they organize their social
lives how they interact how they
petition tasks in a colony and how these
interactions between what the simple
individual insects gives rise to these
very complex emergent properties at
level of the colony but at the same time
that same behavioral complexity also
makes social insects very challenging as
study systems especially if you want to
do functional genetics like knocking out
genes or making transgenic lines and so
we've tried to work around that problem
by working with a rather unusual ant
species the clone radar ant on the order
of two and a half to three millimeters
long so we can keep many hundreds or
thousands in a fairly small Tupperware
box the species doesn't have Queen's
colonies are composed of only workers
and they reproduce asexually so they
don't have to mate but they simply clone
themselves and those features make it a
very good model system if you want to
develop genetic tools in the simplest
form we just keep them in very small
petri dishes and then every ant and such
a colony has an individual color tag so
we interested now in the genetic basis
of the social behavior and so in terms
of the communication we've started to
look at genes that encode what we think
are the pheromone receptors that the
ants used to smell essentially and those
are genes that are mostly expressed in
the antennae of the ants so we have a
set up in the lab now where we can
destroy the function of one gene that's
crucial for the functioning of a whole
group of older and receptor genes and it
turns out when you take out that gene
this whole social communication system
breaks down it just walks around as if
it were looking for the colony but it
has no way of detecting the colony
because it can't perceive the chemical
cues anymore
another part of our functional genetic
toolkit is trying to make what's called
transgenic ants where we take a genetic
construct and try to insert it into the
genome of the ends so we keep the ants
in these small dishes we have inserted
genes to cause these ants to express
fluorescent proteins so if you look very
closely at this colony among the white
pupae that the ants are sitting on top
of you should see one that is visibly
pink these ants carry a different
fluorescent protein in the sensory
neurons of their antennae
so in principle we can look at the level
of fluorescence in these neurons and it
should go up and down with activity in
the cells we started this project about
six and a half seven years ago with this
long-term goal of being able to do
behavioral genetics and eventually
behavioral neuroscience at a level that
at least approaches more conventional
model systems and that opens up a lot of
questions that I think until very
recently were really completely
inaccessible to two people working on
social insects
you